good morning hicks tuesday so important
inventions are almost always created not
by individuals but by broad
collaborations involving lots of people
building knowledge and systems like
thomas edison did not invent the light
bulb and it's common these days to hear
well actually someone else invented the
light bulb but no the solution to
wrongly worshipping individuals is not
to change which individuals you worship
the truth is no one invented the light
bulb it was invented over many decades
of collaboration and competition among
many people and that is almost always
what drives human change but the work
individuals do still matters as do the
choices they make and to explore how
both systems and individuals can matter
at the same time i would like to
introduce you to this lady margaret
stiff who invented the stuffed animal
sort of margaret stiff was born in 1847
in a small town in southern germany and
before she was two years old she
contracted polio which paralyzed her
legs and also caused profound weakness
in her right arm margaret and her two
sisters went to school until they were
teenagers which was quite uncommon for
their time and then they enrolled in
sewing school which was somewhat less
uncommon due to her limited use of her
right hand margaret really struggled
with sewing she would later write that
her two sisters were so capable and
talented where i seemed to make every
mistake that was possible to make they
gave up hoping that i would produce
anything worthwhile with my needle and
it is here that margaret's life
intersects with two much larger trends
first a musical instrument called the
zither was becoming very popular in
europe like this was around the time
that johann strauss ii was writing solos
explicitly for the zither now margaret's
muscle weakness made it difficult to
play the violin or the piano but she had
a wonderful ear for music and she could
play the zither by bracing her right
hand against the instrument she became a
very accomplished zither player and then
started teaching zither lessons and used
the money from those lessons to purchase
the very first sewing machine that her
little town in germany had ever seen she
refashioned the machine so that she
could work primarily with her left hand
and then suddenly she could so despite
her disability at this point she was in
her mid-20s and margaret began a
successful tailoring business with her
sisters but she loved fashion and it was
a little bit of a bummer just to be like
tailoring pants all day long so she
began sewing and selling ready-made
clothing especially these underskirts
made with felt a soft textile that had
made its way to europe via central asia
her clothing became so successful that
she eventually opened up a factory and
branched out into women's dresses and
children's coats all made out of felt
which was so soft and cuddly and warm so
by now margaret is in her early 30s and
to keep track of fashions she subscribes
to all these different magazines and
newspapers that print patterns of
clothing and other stuff that you can
sew and one day in 1879 she's looking
through a magazine and comes across a
pattern called elephant of cloth
margaret later wrote felt was the ideal
material for this toy and the filling
would be of the finest lamb's wool she
was big on quality often saying only the
best is good enough for children these
initial felt elephants were quite small
they resembled and were often used as
pin cushions and margaret mostly made
them for friends and family she only
sold eight of them in 1880 but pretty
soon she was making more stuffed animals
often working from patterns she would
find in magazines she made donkeys and
dogs and lions and bears and even
parrots again though most of these
designs were not invented by margaret
they came from places that published
patterns what margaret saw was that lots
of people lacked the time or the
resources or the expertise to make their
own stuffed animals so she would do the
work for you and probably better than
you could do it and soon a stuffed
animal from stiff became a popular
children's gift because they were
relatively cheap and also because they
were sturdy especially compared to the
porcelain dolls that were the most
popular like proper play thing at the
time by 1890 11 years after she made
that first elephant margaret stiff's
company was selling over 5 000 stuffed
animals per year she then expanded
internationally and things really took
off just after the turn of the 20th
century with the introduction of the
first stife teddy bear by 1907 when
margaret was 60 her company employed
over 2 000 people and was making over a
million stuffed animals per year
margaret died just a couple years later
of pneumonia but the company survived in
fact over a hundred years later they
still make some of the cutest and
cuddliest stuffed animals around like
the rest of us margaret stife was a
product of circumstance had her parents
lacked the resources to educate their
daughters or had the sewing machine not
been invented or had the zither not
become popular or had she not developed
an expertise with felt or had those
magazines not publish those animal
patterns she would not today be
remembered as the inventor of the
stuffed animal and of course in all
those alternate histories stuffed
animals probably would still have been
invented around the same time just as
light bulbs would still exist even if
edison and tesla never had considering
the circumstances and systems that drive
historical change helps us to understand
why those changes occurred but it is
also a window into understanding who
ends up in a position to benefit from
those changes part of what makes the
history of stuffed animals so important
i think is that it's one of the few
places where a disabled woman in 19th
century europe could succeed in business
but at the same time we must make space
for the individual choices that also
help drive historical change margaret
stife saw the potential of ready-made
soft toys for children she made
excellent ones and as her business grew
she was very careful to hire extremely
talented people she attracted and
retained those employees in part by
treating them much better than most
other businesses at the time her
tireless focus on quality control
ensured that stiff-stuffed animals
looked and felt better than their
competitors and her tremendous
self-belief helped her to persevere when
society and even her friends doubted her
ability to become a musician or to sew
or to run a large corporation
so here's to perseverance and to stuffed
animals thanks margaret
hank i'll see you on friday